let's go to the five seven zero area
code five seven zero go ahead
hey David how are you today good we're
not on speakerphone are we I don't know
I had my headphones in okay alright go
ahead I'm wondering why you don't like
Dave Ramsey I heard like in the past you
said you don't really like the guy I'm
kind of curious like he's just sort of a
financial adviser yeah I mean he's just
like he's just an extreme religious
right Christian who weaves religion into
a lot of what is otherwise pretty
unremarkable financial advice and I
prefer to the extent that I get
financial advice from people on radio or
TV I prefer a non-religious approach who
do you take from nobody really I mean I
don't know I could I couldn't really
Nate I mean I don't know I people I know
personally who I talk to about financial
stuff but I couldn't name like any media
people oh yeah okay it's real pleasure
to talk to you today take care the
pleasure is all mine I appreciate the
call and you know someone recently
either tweeted or something the Dave
Ramsey question came to me over the last
week in another platform and I wonder I
wonder if it's that same guy no no